Well. Good morning. We can continue
with our subject of Asiatic cholera.
And I thought we could perhaps frame
that discussion by reminding you that in
the 1990s,
the Nobel Prize winning microbiologist
Joseph Lederer coined a term emerging
diseases.
He used it to describe infectious
diseases that are previously unknown,
at least two sources of human infection
and emerge as it were for the first time
too. In fact, human beings, these
are diseases in our own day.
We can think of Ebola or limes disease,
SARS or of course most importantly,
HIV aids. Oftenly often, uh,
the press,
which seems I would argue to suffer
chronically from historical Amnesia,
it often treats the appearance of new
infections is something unprecedented,
unnatural that never happened before.
But the reality is the
Charles Darwin was correct.
We live in the midst of a constantly
evolving microbial world in which the
microbes have an inherent
advantage because of the
frequency of their mutations
and the extremely brief length
of a microbial generation
compared with the human
one.
So new diseases have always
been emerging and appearing.
And Asiatic cholera is a good
example of what we might go.
Let's be mindful.
It would be historically anocronysms it,
we might call it a great emerging
disease of the 19th century.
There is a scholarly debate on whether
cholera had long existed on the Indian
subcontinent and whether it
went back for centuries or not,
especially it clearly by the early
19th century had an endemic home on the
Indian subcontinent and particularly
the area here in the delta of the Ganges
and Brahmaputra rivers.
That's that area.
There are accounts of diseases,
um,
in various writings that are suggestive
of cholera well before the 19th century.
But that particular debate
is exotic for our purposes.
And what we want to know is
that by the early 19th century,
it was endemic in the Indian,
in the Indian subcontinent,
but it was unknown elsewhere then world
until it burst into a major epidemic in
1817 then escaped India and began.
It's devastating international career
reaching Europe for the first time in 1830
so cholera for the 19th
century was something new,
something never before experienced.
And that helps to explain a lot.
Good.
Part of the reaction to the populations
that were first afflicted by it
as the Great Colorado,
uh,
we should remember was the great
fear disease of the 19th century.
We've already seen that plague was
the most dreaded disease from the 14th
century through the 17th and we know that
smallpox succeeded in that role in the
18th cholera though not the great killer
of the 19th century was the most feared
affliction.
It was feared for a number of reasons.
It's extremely sudden appearance.
It's exotic and unfamiliar character,
the agonizing and gruesome
nature of its symptoms,
its high case fatality rate,
and it's predilection for adults and
the prime of life rather than children.
It's revealing that a great deal of
the discussion surrounding the early
experiences with cholera revolved around
the question of whether this was in
fact the return of the plague.
Some of the names that were given
to cholera capture, the fear,
it inspired.
It was known in all kinds of ways.
If you read the medical journals
of the 19th century and the press,
you see it was called Asiatic
cholera, cholera, more bus,
perhaps very scary,
tingly.
Cholera asphyxia was known as the gypsy,
the monster blue cholera,
and king cholera among
other names as well.
Now, since the 19th century was
an era of acute social tensions,
it was,
as you all know,
marked by a series of revolutions and
is often dubbed the rebellious century.
For that reasons,
you know about the revolutions of 1830
the revolutionary wave of 1848 to nine
across the continent.
When there were something like 50
revolutions within a two year period,
Italian independence,
the Paris commune one could go on,
but due to the fact that cholera
frequently accompanied those events and
indisputably did heighten
social and political tensions,
it used to be common to speculate about
whether the passage of cholera across
Europe was itself a contributary
factor and the coming of revolutionary
outbursts.
By now,
it's pretty clear that the causal chain
actually work the other way around.
In other words,
the outbreak of revolution,
war and social order created conditions
for cholera to thrive call removed.
I would argue in the wake of
revolution rather than triggering it,
so cholera if it didn't cause the
revolutions that mark the 19th century.
There has been in recent literature,
a swing of the pendulum in a different
direction with the views sometimes
express that cholera was dramatic.
Yes,
but not a lasting influence
on the history of the West.
After all.
Some would say that it was dramatic that
it led to all sorts of short term sound
and fury,
but in the longterm that argument runs
its legacy was small and clearly know
where the near the order of
magnitude of plague and small pox.
Well, we'll be deciding among
those conflicting views,
but before we can assess them properly,
we should look in our usual way at the
etiology of cholera at its epidemiology.
It's symptoms and its course in
European and North American history.
Then we'll be in a better position
to judge its impact. Well,
there were seven pandemics
of Asiatic Congo row,
the first in 1817 to 23
which was an Asian event.
The second pandemic was
in the 1830s and did Asia,
but also Europe for the
first time in North America.
The third pandemic of 1846
to 62 afflicting Asia,
Europe, again, North America,
the fourth pandemic from 65 to 75.
Again,
it was global.
The fifth pandemic from 1881 to 96
mainly a matter of Asia and Europe,
the sixth pandemic of 1899 to 23.
Again,
primarily an Asian and European event.
And then the seventh pandemic,
uh,
from 1960 onward that went through Asia,
South America, and Africa.
The last pandemic, however,
has been milder and less
variant with a new bio-type,
the all tour,
which is less dramatic and less
fatal than classic cholera,
which is our subject and which was the
form of cholera from the first pen,
dammit,
through the sixth.
The endemic home if cholera,
it's I've said was the Indian said
continent in the delta of the Ganges and
Brahmaputra rivers and it was confined
there until the number of developments
enabled it to spread the bacterium that
causes cholera is extremely delicate and
doesn't travel so easily.
So it required a number of factors that
enabled the disease to move beyond its
original area of endemicity.
What were some of those?
One was colonialism itself,
which meant large scale troop movements,
uh,
and increasing contact between the
sub continent and the outside world.
The increase in trade did the same
thing in terms of increasing continent
contact.
Then there was the transport revolution,
which was very important
because as I said,
cholera doesn't travels so well over
extended periods of time and it was the
railroad, the steam ship,
and later in the century,
the Suez Canal that radically reduced
the traveling time from the sub continent
to other parts of the world.
Another major factor was religious
pilgrimages and fares in the Indian sub
continent itself and very PR most
especially from the European perspective.
A very important factor was the hodge,
the voyage of pious Muslims to Mecca.
Now that cholera afflicted Europe and
North America in the 19th century wasn't
therefore a matter of chance.
Epidemic diseases exploit features
of societies that are social,
political, and economic
and environmental. Now,
cholera is spread as we'll see exclusively
by the oral fecal root that is,
it's ingested by food and
water contaminated by feces,
and it requires, therefore,
it clearly is, uh,
in among the diseases certainly
that we've examined so far.
Cholera is clearly different
from plague and small pox,
and then it's much more a social disease
that is to say a disease that has a
clear predilection for poverty and for,
uh,
pathologies of social and economic life.
Cholera thrived on chaotic,
rapid,
unplanned,
urbanization with it's overcrowding
and teaming slums within adequate and
insecure water.
This continues to be true
with cholera in our own day.
It thrives on substandard housing.
Yeah,
on inadequate and inappropriate diet.
It has a predilection for port cities,
which are usually the first
place is to be affected.
This reminds us perhaps
of plague a little bit,
places in Europe like
Marsay onboard Valencia,
Naples were among the first and
most frequently to be afflicted.
Cholera thrives also on filth and
the absence of sewage systems.
Cholera is among many
things a disease of poverty,
cholera,
also how to pronounce predilection
for the poor as I've said.
And then that way it
exacerbated social tensions.
Colorado, uh, as I said,
was associated with revolutions though
it followed rather than provoke them.
You can see that the revolt in Poland in
1830 the revolutions of 1848 to 49 when
cholera is often part of the movement
of troops to repress the revolutions
rather than being a factor in there
cause it was conditioned by the 1860
[inaudible] war between
Austrian pressure as well. Well,
what about the disease itself?
The pathogen is this,
the Vibrio cholerae,
which was discovered by Robert Call in
1883 helping to establish the germ theory
of disease. No. Uh,
this will note the flagellum or tail of
the Vibrio that plays an important role
in the human gut.
And we'll talk about that in a moment.
It's transmission, you know, uh,
pretty well because if you're reading
for this week on Jon snow on the mode of
communication of cholera,
you know that this is one
of the foundational texts
of epidemiology where he did
a brilliant epidemiological job
of detective work by finding,
uh,
the famous broad street pump that the
people who drank the water from that
particular pump,
we're the ones who fell ill and took
the disease back to their homes.
Snow did a good job of establishing
the Colorado then was ingested in water
primarily,
although it was also demonstrated later
that fish and vegetables that is food
contaminated with fecal matter can
also play a role. This was, um,
the faint.
That's Jon snow.
Yeah.
And this is the famous broad street pump.
Ah,
that made such an important moment
in the history of medical science and
Epidemiology.
Though it's important to remember that
it may seem odd to you as you read this
book and look at all of snow's evidence
to remember that in fact it failed to
convince the medical profession
at the time. By and large,
there was a big debate about whether
cholera was contagious or not.
We'll be coming back to that debate
and the reasons for and against.
But one of the things was that Jon snow
was unable to demonstrate an actual
mechanism.
There was something in the water,
but he wasn't able to establish what it
was and therefore he didn't provide a
convincing mechanism.
And for people who thought that
probably it was some chemical factor,
if it was anything that snows biggest
chance of making an argument was not,
it would be something chemical. Well,
if so, and remember this was London, uh,
if there was some sort of
chemical in the river Thames,
surely it would be infinitely diluted.
And so how would it be possible
that this chemical substance,
if that's what it was, ah,
was spreading the disease.
So there was a big debate about
whether snow was actually right.
It was proved later in the
century conclusively that he was,
but it's important to
realize that for a long time,
his writing was very far from convincing
the international medical profession.
That didn't happen until
the 1880s and 1890s well,
what were some of the factors in the
transmission of cholera in the West?
We've talked about trade and
the transport revolution.
We've talked about pilgrimages,
we've talked about the strategic
role of sea ports. We're,
once again,
as in the case of flag,
it would be important the bacterium
would gain access to the municipal water
supply.
Yeah.
And there would also be the danger of
swimming or if eating shellfish that fed
on sewage, especially if the
costume was to eat it raw,
the disease would then spread along
inland transportation networks.
We've said to that cholera
was a disease of urbanization.
And if a defective urban infrastructure
infrastructure without sewage systems,
and remember in the 19th century,
waste in European cities was predominantly
thrown into the streets where there
would be a seepage downward into
tank wells that people would then,
uh, drink the water. And
it's bacterial bounty.
Remember too that the many of
the cities of Europe, Naples,
that you're reading about, but
Paris too and many others, uh,
we're surrounded by vegetable gardens
and the vegetables would be brought into
the city and consumed by the population.
But in the growing of the vegetables,
uh,
use was made of urban sewage,
which was collected and transported to
the vegetable gardens outside the city.
And then, uh, the sewage
was used as fertilizer,
which good not to waste anything.
And the plants then grew in human sewage
and then the vegetables were brought
back to town.
So we have a wonderful way for the
bacterium to make an excellent round trip
between the surrounding the
hinterland and the city itself.
This was the practice of sewerage farming,
which was extensive throughout the west.
And it was a good trick that market
farmers knew very well market gardeners,
which was not if you had an
open sewer and they were many,
if you dipped your head of lettuce
and the way to market into the sewer,
um,
then the ammonia from human urine would
make the vegetables look fresh for sale
in the market.
So that was a good little trick that
you might want to remember in any case.
Overcrowding was also another
important, uh, factor in,
uh,
in this.
And I just want you to
remember housing conditions.
These are the fun Daci in Naples that
you've been reading about and you can see
that this is a place if
you use your imagination,
that's a wonderful place
for cholera epidemic. Uh,
not only the, uh, the, uh, the,
the fact of [inaudible]
lack of sewage and wells,
but the fact that it's really dark
and it's overcrowded and people,
lots of people live in a single room
and not single room is used as the sick
room, the sleeping room.
It's a place also work.
Food supplies are stored and with little
opportunity to have clean hands and
remember that the Vibrio
cholera is spread through,
um, fecal matter. But this,
the point is that in these
conditions and in the dark,
it's very difficult to
see. Um, and therefore, uh,
it's difficult to know when contamination
was actually taking place or moving
from Naples.
These are streets and nodding.
Him and England were
cholera also caused a major,
a couple of major epidemics
for similar reasons.
And the waste matter was simply
hurled into streets like this.
And in the center of the street would
be the gutter which would carry um,
human waste as well.
Another source of contamination
is flies which carry the,
um, the cholera, a bacterium with them,
the clothing of victims
that is the bed linen,
the mattresses, uh, and so forth.
We're also sources of infection.
And laundresses were people who were
particularly likely to fall victim and
remember that cholera spread
also by asymptomatic carriers,
it was possible to have to be spreading,
shedding the bacterium
without exhibiting symptoms.
Well,
how was the,
what were the symptoms of cholera and
that I'm going to argue the symptoms.
The symptomatology is an important
factor and the social response to this
dreadful disease and it's caught
captured by such terms as blue,
cholera, cholera,
asphyxia, and the monster.
This is a picture of a representation
of a cholera victim in,
um,
the agony of the disease.
And this is an imaginative
idea of how overwhelming it is.
This is a cholera, a patient
about to be overwhelmed by, um,
the disease itself.
Well,
the bodily defenses are
against cholera are numerous.
The saliva in the mouth
was an important defense.
Uh,
the digestive juices of the stomach are
acidic and tend to kill the bacterium,
uh, when it's ingested.
So it's quite possible to,
in just cholera bacteria without failing
falling victim to the disease itself.
But there are a number of
important variables that condition.
What happens next?
One would be how great extensive,
uh,
the infective dose actually was.
How much,
uh,
did you swallow?
The diet that you're living
on is important because
such foods that the poor in
particular lived on in European
cities as right an overwrite proof and
vegetables and other words,
the poor,
we're likely to buy goods
that were beginning,
degenerate and deteriorate because
they'd be marked down in price.
And those would be the goods
that the poor would live on.
And this meant that they often suffered
from diarrheal illnesses and those
reduce the digestive time and therefore
deprive the stomach of its defensive
capacity to protect you by the
acidity of the digestive juices.
And the consumption of raw fruit,
for example,
would be especially common
in the summer months.
Another factor would be the general health
of the person who was exposed to the
disease.
But let's suppose that you've eaten a
very large infective dose and it passes
successfully through your stomach,
into the small intestine.
What happens next? Well,
there's an incubation period.
Uh,
it can be as short as a few hours and
this to what's important in the social
history of cholera and
could last up to three days.
The site of infection is
the small intestine there.
The flagellum at the tail of the bacterium
that we've seen propels the Vibrio
and it attaches itself
to the intestinal wall.
Ironically, they're the, um,
uh,
immune system of the body is usually
capable of killing the bacterium.
But when it does,
the bacterium dies,
it releases a very powerful
toxin and enter rotax toxin.
That's one of the most powerful
poisons in nature and its effect on the
intestinal wall is to cause
it to work in reverse.
That is to drain fluid from
the bloodstream into the bowel.
And from there it's expelled.
So the mechanism by which cholera Kilz,
first of all,
and predominantly is a sort
of hemorrhaging to death
in which the blood serum
loses its fluid massively.
Leaders can be expelled in
a matter of a few hours.
And the patient hemorrhages to death
in effect losing its blood plasma and
[inaudible] screening what are
called the famous right water, rice,
water stools.
And the patient goes
into hypovolemic shock.
19th century physicians said this is
no longer a fashionable term today,
but they described cholera as
going through two major stages.
The first was called the Algebra stage,
which was the time of
high drama and terror,
which had a sudden onset without warning.
And this was part of the social tensions
that were generated by cholera and
other words you could be seized
suddenly with this dreadful disease,
uh,
out in a public place on a tram in a
marketplace and the streets itself where
you would fall down and start,
uh,
writhing vomiting and excrete eating rice,
water stalls.
This was part of the high
drama of the disease.
And the algae state would last.
If you survived normally
from eight to 24 hours,
it as a patient,
you would lose progressively.
Your pulse would become fainter,
or even almost absent.
The body would turn cold and
would have a livid appearance.
It looked within a few hours,
and this was another of the
frightening aspects of this disease.
Within a few hours,
someone who had been healthy that morning
by the afternoon looked cadaver rised
like a person who had been wasting
away from a longterm wasting illness.
The breath would turn cold,
the hands would look like dishwater
hands and very distressing.
There would be a very severe cramping,
terrible cramps,
terrible abdominal pain,
nausea,
violent vomiting, and
the blood itself, uh,
and physicians who were trying to treat
patients by bloodletting rapidly noticed
that the blood itself deprived of its
liquid content was transformed into a
black tar that refuse to circulate.
Okay?
This could lead to heart failure to a
terrible thirst at the patient suffered.
And because the blood is no
longer providing adequate oxygen,
the patient suffers.
Has the sense of us fixating a
terrible effort to gasping for air?
The,
uh, those are a couple of
pictures of contemporary,
I said cholera is still with us and so
I just wanted to show you a picture of a
patient, um, or another
child patient today.
Okay.
In any case,
if the patient survived the Algebra stage,
there was then the second stage that
19th fuzzy country physicians called the
reaction that might
last four or five days.
The prognosis isn't really better,
but the symptoms are at this time
the cold body becomes warmer,
there's a fever.
Usually the patient suffers terrible
headache and is often delirious.
The problem is that there were terrible
complications that over took patients in
the reaction stage.
Pneumonia was a frequent complication,
so it's kidney failure,
uremia,
gangrene of the extremities,
the ears, the nose, fingers,
toes,
the penis,
and there was a case fatality rate then
from Asiatic cholera in the 19th century
of something like 50%.
Today,
as we said last time,
uh,
there is an effective oral rehydration
therapy and the death rate with treatment
is less than 2% today.
That's partly because of the effectiveness
of the treatment and partly because
the El tour bio-type is less virulent
than classic Vibrio cholerae of the first
six pandemics.
In any case then,
what were the effects on a community,
on a society of an invasion
of a disease of this type?
Was this the return of the plague?
As people speculated,
this disease seemed a little
bit to resemble that in
terms of the terror that it
inspired and the social chaos
it caused during an outbreak.
Now an outbreak,
let's imagine a 19th century city,
you can pick your own,
let it be London or
Paris or perhaps Naples.
The outbreak would tend to begin with
what 19th century medical community termed
sporadic cholera.
Why that way mount a
small trickle of cases.
These would be transmitted in a
neighborhood, a family, a house.
The transmission might be by
contaminated clothing or bed linen,
contaminated food,
hand to mouth transmission from tending
a patient and then not washing the
hands.
Let me give you an example
of from Venice in 1885 there,
there was a particularly persistent
outbreak and a single street before the
disease became an epidemic
in the city as a whole.
And what happened was that this was
traced to a single restaurant and the
proprietor terror was a lovely lady who
happened to be tending to her own infant
child who was sick with cholera
and an upstairs bedroom.
She would go upstairs and tend to him
and then she would go back downstairs
without washing her hands and
prepare food for her clientele.
And that was how the disease was spread
in a single street for some time.
Now in fortunate instances,
the disease,
these outbreak,
this so called sporadic cholera will
just fade away and the community would
escape a large scale misfortune.
But if the VIP Rio gained access
to the city's water supply,
then the disease would flare
up with epidemic force.
And this would be what the 19th century
health authorities called epidemic
cholera instead of sporadic.
And if you made a graph
of cases and deaths,
there'd be a sudden spike
in mortality and morbidity.
Well,
what would be the likely magnitude
of the disaster that would follow if,
let us say a major European city had its
water supply contaminated with cholera?
Well, the order of magnitude would
be different from that of the plague.
Cholera was never responsible for the
kind of demographic catastrophe that
Europe experienced with the black death
or later invasions of bubonic plague and
the 19th century Europe experience.
A major population growth and cholera had
little impact on the population surge.
Let's take again the example with Naples,
a city famous for its overcrowding.
It's filled and it's recurring
epidemics of Asiatic cholera.
Let's compare it also with an
earlier experience of bubonic plague.
Naples experienced a terrible epidemic
of plague and 1656 at that time,
the city had about a
population of numbering,
perhaps half a million people.
The state wasn't very good at knowing
exactly how many people lived in the city
and its statistics for mortality or
also to be taken with a grain of salt,
but there were estimates that as many as
300,000 people died of Boob onic plague
and that single year,
let's compare that with cholera.
In 1837 I chose 1837 because that was
the worst epidemic of cholera that Naples
experienced.
The population at that time was still
round about half a million people,
but in this worst year of Asiatic Cholera,
about 12,000 people perished.
Now,
I don't after our
experience of boob plague,
I don't want that to be a basis for,
uh,
insensitivity.
This an epidemic in which 12,000
people die is a major disaster,
but it didn't have the
same long term cultural,
philosophical and religious impact,
uh,
that the plague earlier had.
And it didn't seem to convince people
that the end of the world had possibly
arrived.
So color compared with
plague is less virulent.
The bodily defenses of healthy adults
are often effective and it doesn't have
those efficient vectors,
routes,
and fleas that enabled the
plague to reach every home.
Also,
unlike the plague,
cholera didn't endure for five
centuries returning every generation.
Cholera first invaded Europe in the
1830s and by the 1860s the history of
cholera in the industrially
advanced nations of northern
Europe was largely over
and for western Europe as a whole.
The 1890s mostly mark the
end and 1911 certainly did.
So cholera had only six pandemic
waves that ever invaded Europe,
and each wave was less widespread and
claimed fewer victims than the ones
proceeding it.
That's a very different history than
the history of Boob OnDeck plague.
Well,
how long would an epidemic last?
It would normally lasts in a great
European city for the length of the warm
summer,
and perhaps the early fall,
it would then recede and fade away
with the new onset of cool weather.
Now,
why would it fade away?
We're Robert Koch who discovered the
Vibrio cholerae set himself that this was
something, a question to which he
couldn't give a satisfactory answer.
He said that this was one of the great
cholera mysteries as he called up.
But we can speculate with regard to
certain factors that seem important.
One would be a change in weather.
Cold Dry weather is hard on the delicate
vibrio cholerae so like plague and
cholera to in Europe had a
very pronounced seasonality.
It struck during the warm months.
Another factor is an after the disease
had struck those people who are most at
risk because of their occupations and
their personal susceptibility and their
living conditions.
The epidemic was then like a
fire that ran short of fuel.
It ran short of people who are most
susceptible and at high risk and then
communities also,
and this was probably important adopted
measures of self defense and those to
help to cut short the outbreak,
especially later in the century when
the disease was better understood.
It's now I'm known to that the cholera
can survive in a spore form in algae
blooms off shore of the great port cities
and so there is a possibility too that
the disease was re-import it'd
from the waters off shore.
In any case, what were the
reactions to cholera in a community
here or there was an analogy possibly
with Plagge and that cholera to generated
terror and fear.
This is partly because of the
agonizing nature of the symptoms.
Of this disease.
And the fact too was that the symptoms
of cholera suggested were analogous to
something that people were already
familiar with and that is poisoning the
symptoms of cholera,
had symptoms that resembled a,
someone who had taken strict
[inaudible] for example,
rat poisoning.
And so people were suspicious that perhaps
this might be a crime rather than a
natural event.
Let me show you some images that convey
the sense of terror that people felt at
the time. Uh, this is,
uh, king cholera. We've
said that's one of,
it's the terms that it
was associated with.
And you can see king cholera
astride the globe. Uh,
and this was clearly a sense of
it's [inaudible] or we can look at,
uh, this is New York City
with cholera approaching.
And again, you can see, uh,
the kind of terror that
was associated with it.
Or let's look as well,
and you can see cholera,
a striding over the defensive bulwarks.
Uh,
those are the kinds of,
this is clearly an Earl,
one of the early pandemics.
And what you can see is the attempt to
control this disease with the plague
measures.
You can see the troops,
sanitary coordinates and all the rest
trying to keep out the monster as it was
called. But those in fact turned
out for reasons we'll be coming to,
to be entirely ineffective
in dealing with cholera.
Unlike the plug or a,
we can see and hear the analogy when
people's minds that this might be the
return of the plague.
It's clear because here we can see the
grim reaper with his side mowing down the
whole population. Or, uh,
we can see once again in the
19th century a revival here.
This is the danse macabre
with death calling people.
Um,
yeah.
Uh, and there you can see
again the dance macabre.
Here's the invitation
of death to come downs.
MMM.
So those are switch of
graphic illustrations of
the kind of fear that this
disease caused.
Well,
it also caused a scapegoating.
So imagine for example,
let's go back to the first,
okay.
Uh,
arrival of cholera in the 1830s and 1830,
let's think of the Russian empire.
Okay.
When cholera struck Saint
Petersburg in 1830 at that time,
Russia was at war with Poland and Russians
believed at the time that the disease
was an act of terror by Polish agents.
So caller gave rise to men
hunts or witch hunts find it.
The search for scapegoats,
foreigners, gypsies,
someone newly arriving in town could be
suspicious and therefore could be set
upon and attacked as a scapegoat.
Colorado also led because of its fear to
mass flight and some cities experienced
almost biblical exoduses with tens of
thousands of people evacuating cities and
fear for their lives and
justice and Defoe's account.
It was the wealthier classes you could
afford the journey and at some work to go
had who went first.
A consequence would be
that the administration and
public services in the city
that was being evacuated more in chaos,
businesses shut down.
There was mass unemployment,
there was hunger and
shortages of all kinds.
There was also a new strain
on class relationships.
Cholera was a class disease,
I would argue,
and then it caused a sharply unequal
burden of death and suffering.
Unlike Plagge,
unlike smallpox polar,
my mirror only shows the poor.
Now,
there are reasons in terms of risk
factors that explain that difference.
There was normally by this time a pattern
of housing segregation that is to say
poor, the poor and the
wealthy didn't live in uh,
next to one another.
And the poor suffered from overcrowding,
filth, poor diet, lack of light,
and the wells they drank from.
We're not the same as
those used by the wealthy.
A good example of this difference in one
that cause a sinister speculations in
time of plague. As you know, those
who tended the plague, victims,
physicians and priests
parish in unimaginable
proportions during the time of
cholera,
however,
doctors and priests moved among the
most sported slumps and yet mysteriously
they manage to stay
healthy for the most part,
while those around them fell ill and died
there good epidemiological reasons for
this.
Doctors didn't eat and sleep and
the sick rooms as the poor did.
They had better diets. They wash their
hands, they drink different water,
but to the urban poor,
the immunity of the wealthier of
classes was highly suspicious.
It suggested to some
the idea of poisoning,
particularly since the poor in the
19th century warrant medicalized.
That is to say they had little contact
and experience with medical attention.
And so on effect,
uh,
during the cholera years
was often violence.
There were assaults on doctors and some
places crowds invaded hospitals and lots
of directors and the suspicions
weren't all in one direction.
The wealthy at this time in the
19th century had a fear of those.
They called the dangerous classes and
they were thinking of the dangerous
classes as dangerous politically.
This was the rebellious century,
dangerous morally and in religious terms,
but also they now seem to
be dangerous medically.
And I think this is a
factor in some of the, uh,
extreme violence that one sees in 1848,
for example,
or in the Paris commune,
there was a strain on
social relationships. Well,
what happened in terms of public
policy and organized effects?
Well, the first thing that happened, uh,
was a tendency to revive the plague.
Measures to contain it.
Collar put unprecedented pressure
on authorities to do something,
to take some sort of effective action.
And it was that the states
responded first off,
Russia, Austria, pressure for example,
by reviving the plague regulations,
Len based and maritime quarantine,
sanitary cordons lots Sorentos.
One can see this and pictures.
This is a cholera Lazzarato or
one can see a here is a cholera,
the Vibrio are arriving and you can see
that the board of health is trying to
stop it and there are sanitary
coordinates and all the rest.
This is a depiction of the early
outbreak or the attempt you,
this is familiar to you from time of
plague to purify the atmosphere by burning
sulfur and with fire.
These were,
or there were funeral regulations and
you can see here again the people bring
out your dead and transporting uh,
the victims to the cemetery for rapid,
hasty burial.
The funeral regulations,
the results,
then we're to maximize terror,
economic disruption and flight.
The plague regulations against
cholera caused political effects,
but they were counterproductive
in terms of the disease,
but they taught a dangerous lesson
that outsiders could be dangerous.
And so, uh, we see then
they don't stop the cholera.
They don't stop the cholera because
they're asymptomatic carriers.
Because the flight of population causes
trying to escape the plague measures
disperses the disease because cholera can
flow and rivers and waterways past the
troops who are trying to contain it.
So the plague measures weren't
effective against cholera,
but I'm going to argue there
what were the longterm effects,
and I'm running rapidly out of time,
but just saying that there were,
I would argue,
not just immediate drama,
there were longterm effects.
Cholera led to a big debate in the
medical profession about contagion,
aneurysm,
rapid or not.
It led to the development of
epidemiology as a medical discipline.
It contributed to the coming of the germ
theory of disease in terms of public
health.
It led to a new set of measures
of sanitary improvements
that we'll be talking
about next time and even to the refitting
and sanitary revolution in cities and
even the rebuilding of
places like Paris and Naples.
Although the color was not the only fact
in places like Paris and it caused or
mortality revolution in urban cities.
We'll be talking more about that.
There are reasons then just say that
although cholera caused many of the
immediate affects of
terror like the plague,
it didn't lead to the
same kind of mortality,
and it didn't have the same
long term consequences,
but it did have a number of
longterm consequences that
I think it's well to bear
in mind. This was the great
dreaded disease of the whole,
of the 19th century.